well and i i think that uh you know
obviously
it makes it easier if the draft's pushed
back and hopefully we get back in the
office you know in two weeks when they
said i'm out on april 9th or somewhere
in that area hopefully we're able to get
back into the office by then you know
really alexis we feel pretty good about
where we are we'd have we'd rather have
it backed up so we can get all our
scouts and everybody in but if it's
limited and we and we can stay there and
they're not going to move the draft
we're in good shape and i think that uh
you know one of the reasons why i think
that you know with the coaches not going
to the combine and them spending the
whole week here just on the college side
it's put us way ahead there because
we've got the coaches rankings already
and so the scouts are already working on
next year a little bit to the 2020
summer manual and so 2021 summer manual
and so we we we feel like we're in
pretty good shape
if it moves back great we're ready for
that if it doesn't move then we'll be
ready for that too
john elway with his thoughts to
denverbroncos.com about the possibility
of the draft moving the general
manager's subcommittee wants the draft
to be delayed gm mickey loomis the
saints has gone on record with peter
king on the peter king podcast saying
the draft should be delayed it's four
weeks from
today chris and look i don't know how
many gm's are going to sign off on this
idea that the draft should be delayed i
think there are some who
are quietly thinking go ahead complain
go ahead advocate go ahead and we're
going to be ready to make the picks four
weeks from tonight and we're going to be
just fine because we're spending this
time
adjusting our approach getting the
information we need and making chicken
salad out of a situation that everyone
has to deal with in the same way i don't
think it's moving i don't care how many
people come out and say they'd like it
to move i think that the nfl is
hell-bent on going forward with the
draft as hell bent as it was on going
forward with free agency last week
and i've just already gotten to the
point of acceptance i'm not even gonna
argue for pushing it back and for me i
don't care i don't have to make the
picks it's up to the teams to figure out
how to do it but i i am convinced
they're going forward with this draft
four weeks from tonight no matter what
anyone connected to any of the teams has
to say
yeah i mean it seems that way and you
know to what you're saying mike
selfishly that i want to see it go on i
mean yeah there's not much going on
there's nothing going on in the sports
world okay so from that standpoint i
just want the entertainment factor you
know the other thing is
i i kind of want to see these teams and
gm squirm a little bit all these coaches
and just see how it plays out but like
john elway i'm not worried about him you
know i know some of those guys that work
for him and behind him the scenes in the
front office they're a very well
prepared group they've had a really good
free agency so far to begin with anyways
and then you know also i just think of
like mike i mean i i don't think we're
gonna hear anybody in new england
complain i bet you they're ready
baltimore seattle i can just think of
some of the top tier organizations where
i just feel like you know they're always
prepared and like you said just a minute
ago in order elway said you know i would
bet you know some of those top tier
organizations they're they're already
feel good about where they are for this
year yeah they're figuring out order and
who they like a little bit more than
this guy and that guy but i bet you a
lot of these great organizations are
already on to next year to a degree
as far as how they feel about those guys
so uh i don't think it's going to end up
being as a big issue as we all think it
will be except for some of the guys that
have red flags with personal off the
field issues that's what's going to
really drive gm's crazy well and
somebody's going to roll the dice on
those guys the question is how far do
they work and they may lose a lot of
money because they don't have a chance
to prove themselves but you made an
excellent point and it's so rare that
you make an excellent point i need to
make sure that we emphasize this
all the time the ultimate reality show
about nothing right it is a tv show and
and the fact that the teams are going to
be squirming is going to add to it it's
giving the nfl more reason to go forward
four weeks from tonight they good you
want to complain about the draft you
want to argue it should be pushed back
you want to point out all the reasons
why we're gonna have a hard time keep
doing it it makes the draft more
compelling chris
right now we're gonna have a camera on
you in your draft room while you're
squirming and uncomfortable and we're
really all going to enjoy it sounds good
to me i'm all in on it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports